[Musique]
vous organisez la deuxième chaîne d'info
de france cannes à 16 de la tnt c'est
news voici nos steven ursino titre à la
une ce matin
nous sommes en direct avec jean rené
girard du snarr le syndicat national des
lycées et collèges bonjour bonjour c'est
jean reno jean rémy excusez moi jean
rémy girard
cet homme flashé à 249 km heure sur
l'autoroute a20 dans l'indre et qui a
expliqué aux gendarmes qu'il devait se
dépêcher pour être rentré à paris avant
le couvre-feu de 21h10 aux données c'est
l'une des questions qui étaient posées à
marie espagnol est ce que j'ai le droit
quand même de traverser rapidement une
zone en cours soit 255 peu trop
rapidement permis suspendu voiture
immobilisée
on m'a fait découvrir quelque chose est
ce que vous savez pourquoi lui masquer
faut lui mettre comme ça vous savez
pourquoi
parce que si lui mais ce qu aulas tu
l'aimé comme ça après qu'ils quittent ya
quelques vides
heureusement pour s'évader il ya
également la littérature et la sortie
dernièrement du dernier ouvrage de
l'écrivain américain jonathan franzen
qui au détour d'une interview dans l'obs
nous allons faire le message d'espoir de
la semaine
la planète est foutue complètement foutu
et nous aussi le coc vite s'attaque
aussi à monaco et le ministre l'état a
pris des nouvelles mesures le
gouvernement décide de limiter le nombre
de passagers à bord des autobus autobus
des autobus à des autobus avaient
compris des compris des autobus
quelques heures après seulement sept
même annonce par son altesse sérénissime
albert ii de monaco qui a erré l'espace
clos dans lequel il se trouvait sans
masque à la fête de la bière de facto en
compagnie d'une rave plein de personnes
un peu comme si emmanuel macron faisait
une chenille juste après une allocution
en renfort
ok mais encore aujourd'hui lundi dans
géante
alors est-ce qu objectif top chef va se
faire avec ou sans francisco est bas
alors quoi j'ai pas le droit de faire
des blagues moi aussi san francisco se
lève je suis contente vous avez fait
carrière dans la cuisine est pas
fonctionné dans la chanson je suis
donnerait une chance sur combien pour
que ça reparte avec claudine 1 700 sur
cinq par son vieux rigoli oui j'ai
envoyé 64 sms tu n'écoutes pas ils sont
inscrits jus le téléphone tu veut pas
rigoler ah bon montre-moi s'être sur
téléphone interphone et savourer pour
même pu non mais tu rigoles et elle va
réfléchir j'ai en tant que ces faits et
avait faux baiser
oui je vais besoin on est en train de
déstabiliser l'animateur n'est pas que
moi c'est la première femme à qui tu
veux des services aux semis ont été
touchés en mai c'est exact et touchants
comme un jeu tu m'as petit clown
tu bien dormi c'est gentil je mange des
steaks frites
non mais c'est quoi ce texto je dis la
vérité je suis une passionnée de
ratatouille
c'est le titre de l'article consacré au
dimanche d'une certaine à pauline qui se
lancent dans une véritable confession
culinaire je cite je suis une passionnée
de ratatouille jeu la cuite très
lentement
je confie les légumes dans des poêles
différente et je les réunis qu'à la fin
détaille-t-elle avec gourmandise le dit
l'article
tu te souviens quand tu m'a proposé d'
apéros tu m'as dit merde tu autriche et
oui tu m'a dit tu veux un doigt je t'ai
dis tout de suite oui j'ai essayé nous
tenu tout de suite
[Musique]
11 min et est parfois là je connais le
matériel de laboratoire un petit peu oui
mais vu comment et pourquoi bas parce
que j'ai été dans l'industrie
pétrochimique pendant 23 ans d'accord
est vraiment des gens qui ne
connaissaient pas le mode d'emploi des
machines qu'ils avaient sous la main ça
peut arriver
ouais mais bon goût ou non c'est plutôt
mercure de ne pas lire des mots d'amour
évidemment évidemment comment tu peux
être aussi intelligent je comprends pas
est ce qu'un cerveau sas muscles comme
le corde à dire genre enfin comment on
peut être plus intelligent quelqu'un
c'est comme les muscles on peut être
plus musclée quelqu'un d'autre ça veut
dire qu'on peut travailler sur
l'intelligence ce média non des
cathédrales ça sert à quoi
c'est des gens et d'analysé de nos amis
les grisons je crois que c'est
c'est une église en plus grand c'est
pour ça que ça serait pas une cathédrale
schwab
bah oui je prends à shanghai au milieu
des gratte ciel se trouvait une vieille
école construite en 1935 qui devait
laisser place un centre commercial
flambant neuf
plutôt que d'être détruite elle s'est
soulevée est parti tout seul ou presque
pas à pas pendant 18 jours elle a marché
quelques dizaines de mètres non non
c'est un cimetière seront ça me surprend
quand même de voir les tombes dans un
dans une cathédrale on le montre au film
et je trouve ça un peu bizarre quand
même
je crois que en fait à temps parce que
je crois que la cades une cathédrale
c'est une église avec un cimetière
voici il y avait des tongs donc
forcément fonctionner la biette
enterrées côte à côte non c'est vrai mon
coeur mais le plus tard possible tout
cas je vais réagir à vos funérailles des
traînées de mémoire faut pas oublier les
votes
andy rain réplique d'oscar wilde oui ou
de dénoncer du mime en fait j'avais pas
du tout conscience que la cathédrale
c'était un lieu saint vraiment pour moi
c'était style comme un musée c'est un
peu honteux venant du damier noir et
d'anémié nous je le sens des mots tus à
l'est c'est un lieu c'est bien sûr et
même sociale et s'est écrite et fit
crier de dents on le savait le taux de
natalité est déjà en berne dans ce pays
eh bien figurez vous qu avec la pandémie
il a tout simplement empirer en 120 ans
il n'y a jamais eu aussi peu de
naissances au japon le gouvernemental
dauchot chouchi cas de dénatalité
extrême - dainville trois enfants par
femme alors qu'on le sait il en faut au
moins deux pour renouveler les
générations dont un peu branché
horoscope tout du tout pour votre action
je m'en balance très bien on recense
désormais au japon plus d'animaux de
compagnie que d'un bébé plus d'hôtels
canon que deux crèches
autre signe ultime du vieillissement de
la population et vous allez voir c'est
édifiant vont désormais au japon plus de
couches pour adultes que de couches pour
bébé c'est vous dire l'ampleur
cette catastrophe